my niece and my nephews they're super
into Harry Potter
they love Harry Potter so much so that
this past Halloween when the Elvis
family went trick-or-treating together
we all had to go with Harry Potter
characters and guess who got to be the
person of Honor yeah my niece she asked
me the day before Halloween she's like
Uncle Mark we talked about it
and in my head I'm like is this an
intervention is it
and she's like we want you to be hairy
and yeah it was so cute and I knew it
was going to break her heart because I
said yes and I'll and I'll do everything
I can to pull off Harry Potter but she's
seven she's expecting the kid from the
movies she's not expecting middle-aged
burned out
hasn't cast a spell in 30 years Harry
Potter
stewardess Gryffindor rope against a
High School varsity jacket